the cruise industry took a hit in the
last couple of years due to the pandemic
but they are ready to welcome passengers
back in here to tell us more is travel
expert Gabe saglier welcome back great
to see you Mercedes All Aboard oh we are
ready to go on a cruise and the cruise
industry it is it is hopping and they've
got some great deals going on right now
you know one of the early casualties of
copen for sure I mean you know there has
a bit of an image issue right from the
get-go when uh with covet hit uh and
it's been a bit of a slow comeback
compared to say you know the flight
industry but in the last couple of
months we've seen a demand ramp up very
quickly and I think cruises remain one
of the biggest sort of bang for the buck
options in the travel industry now so
for people looking to either do a last
minute cruise or invest in a cruise next
year or even into 2024 some good uh
Bargains for sure to be had out there I
went on my first cruise a couple of
years ago and I was really impressed
with how you have the luxury and you
have the food on board but then you
don't have to unpack a suitcase or go to
the airport and you can be in a
different destination in a day tell us
more about some of the big cruises that
people are flocking to right now well
you're absolutely right and there are
some some of these post-covet protocols
that are now part of the experience so
for if you haven't cruised in a couple
of years you'll notice things like more
hands-off experiences when it comes to
the buffet when it comes to entering
your room ordering your drink at the bar
that more hands-free type of experience
which I think makes a lot of people more
comfortable yes in a post-covered era
certainly are now part and parcel to
that cruise experience last month the
CDC dropped its Cruise program so now
it's really up to the cruise lines to
implement things like covet test
requirements vaccination proof
requirements and we're definitely seeing
those be waived MSC which is a European
brand sailing out of South Florida just
this week you don't need a test to get
on board you don't need to be a show of
vaccination proof to get on board they
recommend them but at the end of the day
the threshold the entry now is much
lower much easier and we're seeing this
now across it varies from Cruise Line to
cruise line but pretty much the
industry's trying to make it that much
easier for us so if you were worried
about any of those tests before you no
need to worry exactly it looks like all
of these cruise lines are are kind of
opening their doors what is the most
important thing when planning a cruise
well we on our survey that we did
regarding hey what do you want to see
when you're looking at booking a cruise
destination still is Priority One so the
Caribbean very hot Alaska very hot
Mexico very hot so people are definitely
but even if they're going back to sort
of these tried and true destinations
they want new excursions uh maybe they
want to stay there a little bit longer
so we're starting to kind of expect a
little bit more from our cruises even if
we're going back to familiar places but
these tried and true hot spots for
cruises are going to be hot here over
the next couple of years so glad to have
you back in the studio with all your
expertise you are fantastic so thank you
so much for the great advice it was
great to see you all right Kendall we'll
send it over